joining me now for reaction in Florida
is Dan bungee no and NRA TV contributor
and with me here in studio John Glaser
director of foreign policy studies at
the Cato Institute and Walid Phares a
Fox News national security analyst great
to see all of you John I want to go to
you on this I mean it is amazing to go
back and listen to those who just
several weeks ago we're saying that
Trump was on the verge of bringing us
two thermonuclear war because he called
Kim jong-un rocket man and he seemed to
be all over the place they don't
understand that is the way Trump moves
and operates he is not being given
credit and he he says look anything can
happen here but the the naysayers and
the negativity I don't think are
comporting with the reality that most
Americans are seeing here well it's
important to point out that Trump's sort
of approach to North Korea's not the
only pebble on the beach
I mean North Korea has very recently
achieved what it has always wanted to
achieve with regard to its nuclear and
ballistic missile programs and that has
really strengthened its bargaining
position and goes a long way to explain
why they've changed their posture it's
also the case that so you're saying that
North Korea would have done this anyway
with the Hillary Clinton really is that
what you're arguing well there's other
factors so for example South Korean
president moon jae-in he's had almost
the opposite of trumps approach it's not
been bombast and maximum pressure it's
been conciliation sunshine policy
negotiations etc and he's orchestrated
most of this sort of diplomatic overture
so a lot of credit is owed to him a lot
of credit is owed to the fact that they
now have leverage with their nuclear
program so they feel more on an equal
basis they consider the negotiating
table with the United States so we have
to take these things in there are a lot
of things that are yeah literally this
is what I think Trump is damned if he
does and damn it if he doesn't Willy
because if if North Korea was moving a
pace with more more tests more ballistic
missile tests and of course they've
launched a lot of double istic missiles
they also had a big facility collapse on
itself correct because of the way it was
built whether it was tunneling
underneath thing collapsed on itself
so the whole narrative in North Korea is
collapsing but the pressure that was
brought to bear on him with this
unconventional American leader who
didn't feel like he had to play by the
old rulebook I think
move this to the place that it is now
that nobody predicted no one is
predicting that Donald Trump would be
the one to oversee this this summit and
to carry out this summit again seeing
where it goes I think you're right to
say we have to be cautious but I mean
come on the fact that he's not getting
any credit from these people I think
just dishonest at this point you know I
agree with you during the campaign 2016
I met with South Korean media and
diplomats and they were so far from
what's happening now they even asked me
will a trump administration abandon us
move the troops out and let us be
slaughtered by the North Koreans
everything has changed yes there are
many factors in it but they are very
clear strategic moves by the
administration that led to the situation
we're in right now number one is to
create this East Asian coalition Japan
South Korea number two in my view the
most important deploying the task forces
when the North Koreans saw those task
forces it's it's not it's mathematics I
mean when we we brought all of our task
forces the South Koreans made a
calculation they can't overcome that
they went to the Chinese they asked the
Chinese thinking the Chinese were still
in the 50s China by now is a almost a
capitalist communist regime they want to
make money they are global they didn't
want to engage with the North Koreans
against the South Koreans and that
created a change
so by deploying the forces by opening to
China and by reinforcing the East Asian
alliance that's the angulating with
Japan and China dan bajji no this is how
the New York Times was playing the
release of the hostages coming home
here's a headline at a key moment
Trump's top diplomat is again thousands
of miles away yeah he was going to get
the hostages so they were saying this
leading up to the summit we don't have
we don't have a Pompeo there this is
again after Pompeo was trashed by a lot
of Democrats who voted him to confirmed
him to be CIA director said he was a
dangerous guy I mean I literally think
they're throwing everything up against
the wall to try to trash Trump and none
of it's working the American people like
you know something my life is getting
better I don't know what these media
people are saying they're a bunch of
malcontents damn yeah this this New York
Times story Laura you had one job the
New York Times just one job can you just
ask where Pompeo was okay
probably not going to tell you there may
have been some operational security
involved but maybe just by the answer
that hey we have no comment you could
have figured out maybe he was actually
doing something what a job yeah just get
this story right you had one job what an
embarrassing headline but just on on
North Korea quickly just a double-barrel
he around on what well he'd said before
I think China is well Laura the tariffs
played a big role here the threat of
listen China depends far more on
exporting their products to us and us
buying them then vice versa they needed
us now I'm not a huge fan of tariffs for
you know for economic reasons but I
believe the threat in and of itself and
Trump's unpredictability here which I
believe is strategic has really helped
us and one final thing Laura I mean
forever we've worried if Kim Jong Kim
jong-eun and the Kim dynasty irrational
actors you know finally we have other
foreign countries saying the same thing
about Trump and I think it's a good
thing